welcome to the iron ore podcast episode
number 22 it is a glorious Sunday in the
Lord's are back at the round table we've
got a lot to discuss so we're gonna get
into it
so first off the bat my brother from
another mother the non agro game one
what is going on Lord addict how we
doing sir pretty good I apologize for
missing the last podcast the audience
was moving I moved in now you know which
party I was talking to kid a relevation
brother congratulations I was awesome
bro me Android stuff [ __ ] a kid I was
like made I was like B go B go get
furiously he's like you taking that waka
shave the other day playing practicing I
snapped the picture of it I posted it on
Twitter and I jumped in the room with
him when I jumped in the room because he
forgot here to open check I jumped into
open chat with him soon as I jumped and
he saw my name and jumped out so tweeted
him I said why did you run then he
jumped back in a room and we know we
chopped it up over some other stuff but
I said yeah I got you pictures of you
practicing but you should practice
because I'm a freestyle and of course we
have at the round table the technical
Lord Himself the gaming a soloist the
man who loves the single-player
experience my babe Lord sovereign how
we're doing sir
great man fantastic man went to uh went
to a met game on Friday to pop Duke's to
see to see the the arrival Mets
nice they say whose foot is out at the
back game Saturday that's Friday when we
had great seats they trashed the Rockies
which was miraculous but that was a good
thing so Papa head
Lord Cognito he to man he said I was
like what game are you guys at you I
can't remember what he said you know I
said something cuz my friend was at a
baseball game I don't know how maybe
they play these at the same time they
were literally at the same time he's
like no I was like he was like and then
[Laughter]
[Applause]
the Lord nothing less than the premium
experience oh and of course the Lord
that's out there put his chest on a line
oh man we go fantastic I like to give a
shout out to all the safety first game
shout out to you guys side betting
looking on the sides not been this week
has been a very fruitful week for me and
the family of just coming back from Ikea
now getting to display cases I picked up
their 4k 2017 model what is it this 275
Samsung
q7 nine or whatever that is very premium
is the culet $20,000 on the television
TV cost 10 grand
I got it for a good number
I don't want to put them out there
because everybody call them everything
they bring it this week and I definitely
take pitches and tweak that out and put
that out there for people to check that
out and have them the lords over so they
can see the my man cave we have a lot of
topics and I love the fact that
everybody's been active in the chat and
hit me up on Twitter about these bet
that's what's up that's the self and of
course it is Lord kognito here we given
you that gaming realness
telling you not necessarily what you
want to hear but you need to hear the
kind of glorious glorious week I'm so
excited for the show but before we get
into it last week actually forgot what
apologizing around saying god knows what
they've been playing so let's start with
our Lord addicts what um have you been
playing sir I've been playing a lot of
Halo Wars to like an excessive amount I
actually played halo wars too with the
three top people in the world I mean
they want clearly
no I don't like they it was like an hour
and a half long and they've been and you
know they finally took over it it was
just like we kept fighting for the
middle ground like we push them back to
their spawn and they fought they fought
their way back to the middle ground and
then you know if we fought at the middle
part of the map for like 45 minutes and
then they ended up overthrowing us and
put us pushed us back to our spawn in
one oh no I couldn't I was asked not to
get some friends in that community
yeah bu you go hard for the halo wars
community um when he get his xbox back
that I was buying the game that's what's
up that's what's up
the Lord sovereign what have you been
playing this week sir mostly been
playing on two things
I've been playing for a in anticipation
for Wolfenstein the new Colossus I'm
playing I'm the old blood I went to the
Nord loved it I hadn't played the old
blood yet so I loaded that up and been
playing it fantastic I can't believe me
I mean I can't believe it essentially
just dropped a whole nother game maybe
like a year later it was it's crazy so
and then on PC fire pro wrestling world
howl oh my lord oh man yeah you know
that we we used to play the hockey games
on n64 and we loved those games but if
there was a close second to those games
it was a five pro game and absolutely
hard difficult games and then the
customization options are second to none
like it's fantastic and it's just in
preview on Steam but it's it's crazy you
have like 5000 created characters
already it's ridiculous
nice nice so that's been mostly eat most
of your gaming week with the wrestling
joint yeah that's it
all right Lord King what have you been
playing this weekend's premium streets
of yours I've been trying to put that
arms to work okay and I've been playing
0 Horizon dawn ok it sucks because it's
a really good game but it's
lackadaisical and like ok I like to
compare to the Zelda and I'm not
[ __ ] because Zelda is a true open
world go anywhere have real fun and so
much things to do in Zelda like I like
to compare it to the gamers o tis just
better our problem is it takes us from
being these graphical individuals to a
space of gameplay and like Nintendo's
philosophy is so strong and it shows out
in the Zelda compared to 0 horizon dawn
where Sony's philosophy is the high
fidelity story driven and the any play
is like second to that and right
Nintendo's is all based around the
gameplay and then the graphics comes
second to that and you see it in the
playability of the game it keeps you in
thoose for hours and hours playing Zelda
where this game you know you played like
15 20 minutes and you want to take a
break and trying to find something else
to do so I don't know
blood isn't a Chatterley he said he went
to give you a shout-out Lord Amy said
with that sweet Betty I got going he
said he likes winning hashtag tiger
blood good you know I think for me a
little bit everything for the switch
actually got back in the arms there
dropped up character this week that uh
what does the name brass something all I
know he's beast he's beast I was playing
with that cat
fine I'll put some post up on Twitter
just the new on that he starts doing
that for the young yes box it's been
mostly Marvel heroes shout out to uh
Lloyd
oh yes yeah we've been rocking with that
we've been getting that in actually
dusted off Tekken 7 finally this week
and I was getting in anything with the
story mode and I will say this on the
the cinematics with the story like the
Hirata's production values this year are
crazy so um yeah man I mean definitely
having fun with that so just you know
what it is also working on would tell
you that if you haven't touched yet the
only issues I have the loading times are
so slow and you could tell like I can't
wait for the Xbox one Xbox acting I
think Xbox is doing it now honey p.m.
did they do it today
I think the EPS for pros I'm like damn
this game is it's 7:20 and it's still
beautiful so now I'm like yo I cannot
wait for the Xbox one X version 4k 4k
and just give me the loading times a lot
of times it's Tekken is yeah that's
pretty much what's been going on with me
but obviously crackdown is the source of
much discussion this week in these being
Street and you know the Lord's gotta
attack it and give our take on it so uh
Lord addict what's going on with
crackdown man talk talked it took to the
roundtable the fact that everyone is
talking mad [ __ ] about my cabarrus kids
are listening that awful Mike Ibarra
when it comes down to it like look like
that you know at e3 they showed our
horrible reputation of the game uh you
know I got hands on it for a couple
minutes I didn't played a whole lot they
had you on like a ten minute timer or
something like that so I played a little
bit of that I didn't even play the whole
ten minutes because I was talking to one
of the dads for Halo Wars - you know how
I go about that so yes so I had to get
up I had to get up out of the situation
[Music]
and now they've showed a gameplay they
gave it to a popular youtuber so to
bring more light on the subject what
your I personally got you guys you guys
remember when they went crackdown 3 was
show I was disgusted even what I played
it you and I was sitting together and we
yeah we generally had the same feeling
about the game and I was look I was like
the game not saying the game you know is
bad I'm just saying when it comes to the
visual aesthetics to the game that's
lacking but so you know what they they
showed this gameplay and what they
showed actually made me more
anticipating on it like a lie I
apparently had a complete opposite
effect with everyone else but like I'm
just looking at this dude taking a
portable black hole shooting it
everywhere so you know I was more I was
like yo the game might not look the
greatest but it looks fun as hell but
yeah everyone else did not have that
that same feature and people were like
this game I and it's like I've said in
the past I feel like you know us as a
community you know I'm not saying
everyone in this this chat I'm saying
the gaming community seems to [ __ ] on
graphics before Dave wood and I felt
like I feel like gang play should come
first before almost anything maybe
stories the only other thing that could
come before gameplay and you know I feel
like we've lost touch with stuff fair
enough fair enough um anyway was to jump
because I definitely let's say on this
one too because
was sitting together and we had the same
discuss when we saw Terry Crews jump on
the screen um I thought they'd spend a
wad on Terry Crews up the you know I'm
talking and I also thought Terry Crews
did himself a disservice by nineteen so
um the game looks like crack now one and
4k mm-hmm with a little added features
to it maybe I noticed that we didn't see
the destructibility that they talked
about that they hyped up that they said
we will see with the cloud and it's
making these playstation guys and his
ponies Sony's whatever you wanna call
them say all that cloud stuff was a lie
I told you other lies Microsoft for
lying and I can't defend it because I
didn't see it I played the game and
unlike a lord addict who didn't play the
whole ten minutes and talk to the dev
about another game I actually played the
game and I actually was looking for
certain things and I still walked away
with feeling that I had all the
crackdowns
and his crackdown one in 4k and they're
heavily relying on a 4k factor that
people have a 4k television to get that
visual pop yes the cartoon aesthetics of
the game shows well on a 4k display but
then again how does it look on a 1080p
display yeah how does it play on a 1080p
display so I really think that they're
banking on a 4k push with that game to
give it that pop that visualization the
colors look really good
it looks very fast but then again I saw
slow down you know and I was worried
about that because I'm like calm bro
just a shouldn't have any slowdown is
hardly any textures in the game like it
wasn't really populated over the other
popularization of the was a 360 version
so really bros like but I understand now
why Phil didn't end on that game mm-hmm
no I definitely am on I mean lo saw if
you want to jump into because I
I got stuff before Soph jumped in
actually Hank legas got some stuff going
on today he said he's world of the
street as Terry Crews crawled back to
Microsoft after Blizzard distant for
that like he was like today tomorrow you
will be dropping buildings laughs what's
your feeling on this crackdown stuff
well I mean coming out to be three hours
one of the ones that was kind of more I
wasn't as hard on it as you guys I was
saying you know what it did look like
crackdown one it looked like there was
more stuff going on it but it didn't
look like much more than that was like
you know what fine that that's what it
is um the thing is that yeah if you're
gonna launch this with the X you have to
you have to make it stand out of some
way shape or form like I always felt
that being that the game is sort of
cel-shaded it's sort of it sort of takes
away from from details that the game
could possibly have because everything
is sort of very crisp and clean it just
doesn't lend itself to being a like a
graphical powerhouse because the
hardstyle the art style doesn't lend
itself to that all right so that's
something again maybe they should have
read rethought that you know because you
would be excited for crackdown nobody's
excited for it it may just be fine which
is you know which is fine it'll be a
perfectly serviceable game but they they
need kind of need more than that now the
whole destructibility thing in their
defense they did say from the very
beginning destructibility would only be
in multiples or what they did we'll see
what they did say and this was a long
time ago so you kind of have to take it
with a grain of salt also they had said
that their co-op multiplayer would also
have the destructibility factor but they
never said that co-op multiplayer was
gonna be campaign so to me it seems like
their co-op multiplayer is also some
other side mode in addition to regular
PvP rival T player that also who's
destructibility so my understanding is
that co-op within campaign
is also going to have the same level
destructibility meaning like cars um you
don't stuff physical stuff in the world
but not actual buildings not landscaping
I can be able to do that but you will
destroy physical things no I'm not oh
yeah that's the thing look at videos if
you look at the videos you can see them
destroying stuff like cars and stuff
like that stuff industry you see it but
again it's not what people are looking
for people are looking for things
falling down huge explosions and they're
not showing that that's the thing if you
look at the video you will see cars
exploding them picking things up
throwing them at people yeah but that's
crackdown what exactly are we talking
about is that demo that you showed us at
2013 and say yo check this out and we
look at the building crumbling like it's
doing it wasn't and Weezer the clothes
control the environment you should put
it the multiplayer some reason this
multiplayer is not been seen over from
Gary's work for it lets you get more on
it this is why they haven't really been
focusing on it's gonna be hopefully it's
fine and it's good but I think it's just
gonna release to kind of like a ho-hum
reception I think the Lord you guys
making points I want to shout out what
attic to because I do see where he's
coming from and I'm of the mindset that
look I want to give the game change
right the game I'm not the biggest crack
down guy obviously obviously the game
came out the first one it was well right
now the second one not so much right but
it's one of those things that it's like
okay I see the potential and if the
Terry Crews thing I thought that was
great promotion you know to get someone
like that to breathe life into the
franchise to get a little excitement
pumping but shout out to tick and
shouting I'm gonna be money from ticks I
was listening these guys this week and
he made a good point
it's like
what they are showing is not getting
anybody hype enough for this game in my
opinion this is your flagship game in a
sense you're dropping this in coinciding
with the system what Xbox one X this is
technically a large game in a sense for
Xbox one exit isn't the release date
around the 7th right so it's one of
those things it's like okay you know I
understand the logic behind people
saying well it's not really a triple-a
like that but what else is there and
it's launching with the system so you
kind of have to push it that way and I
think ultimately it just comes down to
they are not marketing and advertising
this correctly you spent I can say like
clock Kings they almost feel like they
spent the budget on cruise and that was
cool but when it came to the game was
okay what are we actually doing right
they're gonna put the game in with the
Xbox one X that you can't complain about
it either way
anyway to do that I think that would be
a genius move to sell it I mean it's
it's not presidency they've never really
done packings at Microsoft to my
knowledge I thought that would be great
yeah I mean absolutely that to move the
system I disagree in command I think I
think that rising 30 was the more
pilling in the crackdown is at the
moment
Kelvin Brandon he's saying that on crack
country started development on the OG
xbox was never built from the ground up
on his club dev kit and that is true all
I'm saying
all I'm saying is this you know
obviously what they show previously like
Lord King said was destructible in Ron's
okay granite like more sovereign said
this is what they had also said that
that's supposed to be for the multi
player all I'm saying is showcase it in
some form it's almost like this mom we
can't talk about it and it's like yeah
do that this close to launch we are you
know we're getting there you know
obviously we got a couple miles away and
there's still time for shine there's
still time for a lot of things to be you
know added it's just one of those things
that it's just like I don't understand
the logic by keeping everything behind
closed doors and we still don't have a
sense of what's going on for the Xbox
one X and it might be a sale game at a
discounted price for the regular Xbox
I could see that happening um for those
people who are fortunate enough to have
an Xbox one X those are the people that
might have a 4k television or plan on
getting a 4k television so they will see
the game completely and they can you
know get on Twitter Instagram and
Facebook and spread the gospel about the
game and play the game and the numbers
arrived from there and it'll also show
like it let's say the system cells and 2
million last night you know and the game
would sell 2 million because it's a pack
in game so the numbers will be there
they can show the numbers and then
whatever numbers that the regular Xbox
1x know feels kind of like that's kind
of it's not that it's shady but that's a
shady business practice it's like you
know what I don't think well let's say
uncharted 4 we all know that game was
gonna sell well regardless but it's like
you know what I don't think uncharted 4
is gonna do as well as we anticipate but
you know for our shareholders at the
next meeting
hey let's let's bundle this [ __ ] in with
the ps4 and act like it's so 9 million
you listen my thing is this I want the
game to succeed like I really do like
I'm not hating on it's just what I've
seen in my opinion has not been
impressive it's just to me kind of like
a up reg 360 kind of game random you
know it looks it looks like it could be
fun
but you're not doing anything basically
I want it to win in the sense that I
want a person who's on the fence who may
have a PlayStation who's looking into
getting an Xbox one X right yeah you
ain't not exact right now they're not
they're not swag that guy multiplayer of
this game I have a lot more faith in
than now because I've seen the way the
game looks there's got to be reason they
chose the game to look like that I mean
I get that you know they did the cel
shading just like they did the other
ones but you know you could do so cell
shading and it looked better than that
Murphy does better than that but you
know let's keep it real you know
if they come out their games gone and
they show a fully destructible in deal
it's safe fun multi rare experience
people can have a completely different
tone it's like absolutely backside of my
uh my video I've made a couple of plays
yesterday or the day before it's like
look like I'm gonna wait for that I know
people you're gonna get on me for saying
all we waited for e3 that is completely
Microsoft's fault they chose to do data
for a conference and not their own at
home which you know people I think
that's a mistake because a lot of people
a lot of casuals nobody three is you
know I can walk into a party be like yo
you watch III you like nah man what
happened if I say yo you watch games con
what the hell is games gone it's a
Microsoft defense they lost Europe and
to gain Europe you have to show a little
bit of favoritism
now do you point yeah do you use that at
the sacrifice and taking us for granted
I think that will work against me that's
a good point
you know because if you don't show your
loyal fan base some type of favoritism
and you and it goes back to ruin Japan
they keep warming Japan to keep going to
Japan the fact that we all over here
we're like you'll mess with those dudes
over there don't really mess with you
like that you know you can say oh yeah
we got some stuff for you if you want to
come over but you putting yourself out
this stop Rob Kardashian a situation
over this spend that money at home when
we really appreciate it
Europe is notorious foaming it's
notorious Sony so the sony has Europe
sony has Japan now Nintendo has Japan
now only foothold is Europe that's what
he wants to do for the FIFA I don't know
how everyone acts like you know in this
off talking just a tad bit yeah like you
know the fact that Microsoft doesn't
have a foothold in Japan matters I'm
like yo like I've seen on the weekly
place they should only sell like 5,000
units they're like no one buys consoles
Japan yeah and it's a testament not to
go to of time like you said it's a
testament to water switches being so
successful over there because I'm mobile
is really their space it's a smaller
environment smaller apartments you know
that kind of big the console space is
really kind of die nobody but back on
track would you look yeah I really think
Microsoft if like Lord addict says they
decide to do that in Gamescom mm-hmm
that's a smack in the face two holes
actually fattening your pockets because
these guys are lukewarm which you at
best
over there you're not gonna take away
that the the fan base from that area and
you might say well by doing this with
show and a road something no make good
games good games will sell systems
period but you you fatten up your your
fan base because a lot of guys in this
generation are looking over at the
PlayStation they're looking over at the
switching like wow those games are cool
over there and second systems is being
purchased and those second systems are
games that could have been purchased
here for me to is also just real shout
out to look you guys have you guys
watched this I know lot attic guys have
you guys watched this what is it twenty
one minute footage of the game so far
yes yes okay Louis up get over yeah yeah
yeah what was your film that seems to be
the point of contention
one thing that I expected more out of a
the animation the animation is much like
it was on Xbox 360 like I expected the
agents to be able like the climby
animations to be more fluid I expected
you to be able to do by just wand eyes
off of buildings like these are
super-powered agents and like us again
the movement is stilted just like it was
before I understand you're running
around and shooting but it's it's still
it just doesn't feel as smooth as a game
you know again when when to crackdown
won't come out mm set six seven three or
something like that
[Music]
they address the fact that people didn't
like crackdown 2 and they in they
focused on what was best about crackdown
1 but it doesn't feel like they've done
enough with that for ya you know what it
is for me sovereign to just to jump the
harp on it is that for me a guy that was
kind of even lukewarm with crackdown
what I need to see new gameplay
mechanics I need to see something you
know what I'm saying like I understand
is this kind of like you know rough
rough rag-tag blow up stuff you know to
be honest no to this is coming from the
developer that did grant the photo yes
okay so his concept for the whole thing
is like do you like jumping in cars
right you like shooting stuff right so
wouldn't it be cool to climb a building
just jump all and just oh stop yeah okay
that concept you already did that
already let's get some animation and I
was playing a retro game no King but we
was in my face was our animation of his
feet on the ground in a time zone I was
in the 360 and a good hard and shout out
to you know guys in the chapter it's
like I understand it's not the finished
product I know for me I'm probably still
gonna come but like I said like a dog
I mean I went I went afterwards to the
booth with very respectful I know these
devs I don't want it I'll never
disrespect adapt his face you know he's
one of those exactly but I made that cut
cake is dead he's you know he's in the
game so I'm hype about that I'm gonna
you know what that's fire you know Lord
that cupcakes in it you know that's cool
I'm just looking at the game lamb say
yeah yeah you know I mean kind of thing
cuz the Lord our cupcakes do some
climbing animations you need the motion
cap some stuff like that a little bit
more hopefully like something in I will
say this before we move on go for I mean
yeah they're the way I see it they're
banking a lot on this multiplayer and
you know we'll see what happens with the
multiplayer games calm but I feel like
this could go two ways and now I'm
leaning more towards like 4060
by the expansion to Halo Wars too before
I pick up crack shots
probably be with Lord addict on that
because I actually really stopped
purchasing Xbox one games in
anticipation for the Xbox one X like I
didn't buy Tekken I have to buy you know
it's about we're waiting for the X
enhanced features right isn't that on
launch day with animation okay now
here's the thing if first off the game
is not long this year it doesn't like
the fact that that's coming out November
it's got way too much way looking more
promising games coming out around the
time than it does should be much yeah
and you know it's not like a console
launch so no this game should come out
that's what it should come out yeah I
give it a March empty date like you know
like switch did when they did they fell
in March and he soaked it up and because
it's not really anything really hanging
out in March you got those people with
the income tax dollars and that's the
thing that's the thing when you look at
this game they're making the same
mistake that was made with Dishonored
last year they trying to push the game
that's a great game in terms of
Dishonored
but it's trying to push it like it's a
game they can compete in November and it
can't we get a tail next up my question
is y'all would real quick because I have
to ask solving and said you guys know do
is it co-op throughout the entire case
yes you can poke her though is it for
[ __ ] I'm a sucker for co-op though see
that's where they got me that's what I'm
not saying that okay I'm not saying they
know was not I'm not saying no one
should not pick this game up because
it's you know it's worth the purchase if
I gotta say the price though you can't
be saying that and after you contradict
what price it should be if it's for
player multiplayer for the entire for
the entire campaign
dude all company what if the campaign is
only four hours long we go blow these
buildings into it yes that's what
Microsoft does do you have friends peer
pressure the guy if you give me game
that they're not gonna play later like
listen that goes back to see I got seed
again in my system I'm upset I know ha
but um yes it's definitely something we
needed to talk about and actually I
wanted to bring the next topic to the
roundtable because I don't see anybody
talking about this and I'm a firm
believer that video game history
sometimes repeats itself so as I was
looking at the upcoming release dates of
all the titles for the for the holidays
came to my attention that there were
three titles that drop on October 27 and
I'm picking rabbits overall well
actually met a rabbit is not one of them
actually it's Mary Odyssey yeah I can
wait on that game Assassin's Creed
origin actually has a following who
would have known I'm a pastor now keep
in mind with no Mario Odyssey is a
launch title we know the anticipation
for that game right we understand the
insignificance of marriage of the switch
then we have our sasses Creed origins
back to Egypt the essence changing the
gameplay mechanics
I moon run the Pharaoh then we got
wolves damage I honestly did not care
about too much until I found out shadow
to Windows Central that it is getting
the 4k HDR treatment and now the
question is was it the 60fps going down
with with Wolfenstein Ingenix I don't
follow you okay the O blood are you
purchasing and if so after you decide
which game you person that should be in
the spot listen and I'll break this
really darling this really is the for
those people this out there listen
Mario's no so cuz they don't got any
games over there
so Mariel was selling all right Mariel
will sell is gonna push systems if you
say you don't like Mario that's on you
that's your problem that is pure utter
gameplay Mario is purchase it's a fun
game it's just there's too much good
[ __ ] coming out for me to validate that
person no I understand what you're
saying
I got a switch for that y know waited
who didn't pick up Zelda said that they
were just waiting area mat scenario to
be announced I was like really okay
arms
all right you said to me Assassin's
Creed now I've been picking up
Assassin's Creed since the first one
right and I got the unity and I got the
this thing pump crap and I was like kind
of wearing down on it and they took the
time off they did the side-scrolling
thing to test that out to see if people
liked it I played that game that's it
that's my game of the show to be honest
with you physically the game plays
beautifully aesthetically the graphics
is to die for and it was showing it on
4k screens
I just wanted my 4k televisions we are
good we're ready we're fine
in this whole section it is really
anticipating that specific game so if
you tell me when I walk in a store what
was thing that me would come out yet it
didn't you then you're Michelle for no
reason for no reason
okay you're not even the premium
experience my friend not know what he's
a dig but not none of those gangs out of
the three a do it for k6o know what okay
my honest opinion is you can't come out
of September destiny lock that up all
right people are lucky their deaths they
went to beginning the monk because they
gonna be skip a school plan again Oh
take the game just like we sell a
crackdown move that to march of February
go out there where you could play in the
grass and everybody can appreciate you
you listen the last Wolfenstein had got
lost and then people was like I played
it was fantastic and word-of-mouth made
the game actually sell I got one and two
and after playing one you definitely
gonna buy two um and I understand what
Lord sovereign is on it he's definitely
gonna get three but are you gonna get
three at that day are you gonna make it
a two hundred dollar price point day to
yourself I'm getting
three on eleven seven 2017 it's not
getting touched before that there's no
reason okay a good point and actually
I'm glad you said that because in all it
is they also is that factor of the Xbox
one X treatment and games that come out
prior to the Xbox one X you know are we
waiting on so in your case Assassin's
Creed is not even an issue because it
comes out it comes out for you in
November several exactly that's
precisely the only game that comes out
for me that day is Mario that's the only
thing I'm worried about that day
so Wolfenstein does nothing to no no I'm
not gonna I'm not gonna do it your
Wolfenstein like that I'm me and it's
experiencing on the X G sports is also
coming out October the Lord's gonna be
tough to compete with but uh Lord at it
talk to me the murderers row October to
have a Yahtzee Assassin's Creed in
Wolfenstein I get the vibe now you might
not make you free I don't know what's up
Wolfenstein Mario my I mean I might get
my I mean Wolfenstein ain't even coming
near my xbox I will be honest with you
I'm the of it's nothing it's nothing
about the game it's just I didn't play
the first one because I wasn't it's just
that gameplay I don't like that point A
to point B mentality their games be
happen I just don't like it I'm sorry oh
you don't like you don't like a linear
experience there's certain linear
as I can get down if one that really
immerses you in the game but I don't
even really see that in Wolfenstein like
you know like I tend to if it's if it's
linear experiences I tend to lead more
towards third person at third person
shooters because I don't know why like I
feel like they do that better but like
when it comes the first person's bad
it's just like open-world or nothing
okay so now that that brings it down to
you to Assassin's Creed origins versus
memory and potentially both of them
could get caught like you know I it just
depends on how how bored I am at work to
play my switch gun to your head gun -
yeah now you're in a unique position
because for my understand the last time
we talked you're not necessarily running
out day one Xbox one X right so no my
understanding is that you're gonna be
you're not doing waiting for the Xbox
one X treatments or Assassin's Creed's
origin is a legit purchase for you am I
am I certainly correctly yes very
okay an assassin creed I for those who
you probably don't know this I've played
every Assassin's Creed vicinity exactly
how me and you Lord addict met one of
our first best to get you to play
destiny was the Assassin's Creed trade
whatever yeah like a game that destroyed
the entire franchise to me also I know
about my man Lord Atticus he is really a
Muriel rabbits fan as opposed to it
gotta see our Odyssey was getting cocked
and toss all rivals and then remember
rabbits is August so you could have
rabbits you gonna be good rep yo I could
play I could play those ex-con things
multiple times
no but gun to your head
origins versus Mariel which one is Lord
addict picketed hmm I doubt the same
Odyssey okay it's just because shadow
wars coming out I got plenty of stuff I
could play on my console my switch has
been dry yeah same here
I mean look you made it my point for me
I didn't think that's what it came down
to me because I said at the end of the
day like world king said all right Alec
said endless off is just the switch this
is their showcase game this is what we'd
be wonderful
we're gonna be able to take it on the go
we're gonna do what not it's kind of
hard for me because I've stayed away
from Assassin's Creed I got very upset
with them with analyzing the franchises
I didn't even mind that because I always
said as long as they improve the
mechanics and make and you know have a
solid story I don't matter I don't care
how many they pop out
I can't felt like Rogan uh what's Rogan
unity coming out the same year was a
little weird
is when I was dating dating because
you'd be had hoped for and I felt they
did that look as well King says the
baton switch I thought it was gonna be
more play co-op block the entire game
and when I get directly through it they
desk you can bring you me and I'm like
no this is not what I said that wasn't
even the problem that was not even the
problem is it looked like a PowerPoint
it would not rain we see what we see
what cuz that was the one what he had
all the crowd guys and all that stuff
going on yeah you could clearly see why
that you know this game was looking like
it looked like a PowerPoint like and you
know what you know John tried to tell me
he didn't encounter any of these
problems I said John you don't go
somewhere I swear to god he had the Xbox
1s I guess way before wider and it
looked like I looked down and it
literally looked like I was presenting a
PowerPoint at work shout out the Fez
back of the cat just talking that
premium Turkey getting both and I feel
you dig again with the Assassin's Creed
for me like I said like I turned off
towards it I'm buying Kingdom Hearts 3
on xbox oh yeah we all banking was three
um so when I saw origins and I'm like yo
they redid the mechanics
it looks more kind of RPG issues with
hurry yeah and I'm like I'm a sucker for
Egyptian history like I'm a sucker for
that you know that whole timeframe I'm
even about the pre-order to giant
because I think they got some special
mission with a period
so I'm in they got me knotted now come
down to okay you know switch Mario says
it's creep and I got a link with my man
Laura sauce and say like I'm not trying
to play that in the inferior version I'm
not trying to see PE choppy 30fps I'm
not trying to do it so my thing is I can
wait a week
right cuz October 27 then just like a
week after so will be the Xbox one x
release date then I will get it's
alright rock Mario for that week strong
get a little blazing right and then from
there when it comes down here comes and
Creed it comes a couple other ones but
maybe sleeper because the first one was
a sleeper but now everybody you know the
sales that's been going on the mortar
right and let's be honest an entire
franchise like they basically we across
promoted to get people just to pick up
their old title now not a lot of people
picked up and it was cool that water is
doing is that feature that's allowing
you to bring your dude in from the
Nemesis system over to the new nemesis I
have a dude on my cup like a beard yeah
he's coming with me
hard body is that I think I think it
allows you to bring him over to whatever
system you want so if you played on ps4
the app brings him over keeps me kind of
like in a queue and you can even bring
him over to whatever version you have so
if you switch over to X 1x I you can
move yeah I think the Nemesis system is
the greatest system shadows more it's
like I've told you guys before previous
shadow borer is a shadow more and dying
either the two prime examples I can use
for this are examples of companies that
make a good game that sells off its name
and that sells off the name of the
developer
mmm definitely so yeah man the murderers
row October 27th saw the devs make good
games and you stop bitching about
yourselves it's gonna be a fun day so I
can't wait so we're gonna move on to the
next topic myself when it's done with a
the murderers row and yeah we want to
bring this over to my man Lord King
we're gonna talk about the Nintendo
switch in these ports what's going on in
these streets Roger
well he's noticing a shout-out to
digital foundry for highlighting this
you know always give credit to the
sources um you know the switch has a lot
of ports of Wii U games and there's more
games coming that has been stated like
oh what's that the mighty 101 something
like that and the Bayonetta series
should be making it over to the switch
and getting the switch treatment you
know the switch also gets treatment too
they get bumped up to they keep that
solid 60 frames per second 1080p or 900
you know P you know they're doing a bump
game too um my thing is why aren't they
getting the the hatred and the vitriol
ah we can't stand the fact that their
support and when other systems you know
they put their games over and the hatred
is through like PlayStation was so hated
on with a whole HD lineup that was
coming out not too long ago they were
like destroy yeah I'm picking that up
next week topic first okay to be fair
when Microsoft and PlayStation we're
doing it they had other [ __ ] to play
like let's be real here out of every
company that needs as many HD remakes as
they can Nintendo is above every
you're comfortable with rehashing on a
system that doesn't have any games and
option
I've always simply started I have no
problem of remittance like even when
people are remaining the other games
like you know for the most part all
these remakes even a Nintendo that
they're done by small team working like
this is racing we got this new gonna
love it they don't put on exclusive game
now on I think the reason they don't get
hate is for two specific reasons I can't
I can't abide by the price thing the
price thing that's you know that's and
that's the Nintendo tax everybody pays
people
they know people gonna pay it and
they're gonna put it at that price and
then just like that whatever is it right
no not at all but the reason they don't
get hey is a for a lot of people these
are new games a lot of people really is
on Wii U you know how many we use so
maybe 14 million something like that
there's still people out there that
think the Wii U is an extension of the
week probably yeah so I mean a lot of
search for a lot of people DS up right
did you get the with you why is that was
that like a controller and secondly is
the portability factor it's just the
fact that a lot of these games if you
look at them if you ain't know somebody
might you might be like well you know
what I don't really feel like playing
this game on my console sit in front of
the TV but the fact that it's portable
makes it that much more appealing I mean
I've had this conversation with low
kognito I have this conversation looking
like it's just it's the portability
factor just adds another layer of
intrigue to the game that makes you say
yeah I'll pick it up cuz I can play it
whenever and wherever no that's why they
don't get the hate for it there is
technically a double standing bias is
not even that's definitely true for this
is it for me it's just like you said
it's like the Wii U factor I definitely
represent the people who didn't pick it
up and you know fall and that's what to
us as new titles but anyone looking from
the outside in yeah it's like okay
what's going on here I guess the thing
with me which I'm actually kind of
little day I want to go a little off
topic with the ports I'm actually happy
that they're showing that okay look that
system that we had it didn't do well the
previous system but now that we got the
power now we got the right marketing
look what is to do one now and look at
the sales and I think as a result of it
it's showing these third parties and
showing these other companies I mean I
was surprised y'all we get in the WWE 18
yeah like that's crazy like to see two K
jump behind this stuff so to me that the
fact that they can remix these all hours
act like a brand new and then they the
proof in the pudding because they like
look we went platinum you know so what's
up now it's like in a way it's just
forcing the hand of green developer
the part that was on the side kind of on
the outside in looking now say yo
numbers over there we gotta get in you
know so that that's how I look at it I
mean there's there's no making excuse
you can bring them over hey come on in
you're bringing fresh stuff we like
fresh stuff that's new bringing new
stuff um but Nintendo is bringing in
these okay true I mean one other point I
want make today looking because it Lloyd
touched on it
see I'm Odyssey like I'm not to be
Master hater right
I'm the guy that's like look if you I'm
Pro studio in the sense that I hate to
see studios dissolve
you know like THQ and all these other
people over the years claim like so my
thing is if there's a house who footed
for the third party studio to be like
look this is one of our beloved joints
we're gonna put it back out let's see
the reception right we got Final Fantasy
salmon coming let's be honest remaster
old game but it's so beloved and if this
can help keep the studio alive I'm about
it now I get the side that says oh I
rather you make a new IP and stop
rehashing old joint I get that but my
thing is okay a lot of us ain't buying
these new IP Ziva let's keep that it's
not even the original developers that is
actually making these remixes so it's
not we're supporting the dev that made
the original game to begin with what's
the poor in the Sideshow Bob do that is
probably getting the extra money it's
coming back to them some way I think for
me is more of a thing that like if I
love a title or franchise game I
remember I used to play like I'm gonna
support it like if there's a new
iteration and I feel that they've done
enough with the remaster to support me
going out to get it
you know I mean then I'm a you know
saying but you know I get it the people
have the right to say no I'm not falling
for this hustle I'm not doing it but
look at this generation right well I
mean people have nintendo crap when the
Xbox one and ps4
we got gta5 we got here people crying
too much I mean what did people's people
were crying he was saying okay he's a
lot of remaster going on and that's when
the whole we saw with GTA 5 did in MPD
we saw with all these games Hey what is
it uh the one that's coming to switch
also that was remastered for um was it
paid all these things that was 360 games
just coming on back slap a coat of paint
you know on what's the other one with
the Japanese GTA what does it Sleeping
Dogs yeah you don't say like so much of
this stuff I kept seeing come about the
woodwork and be okay you you may think
that I'm against this right because I
was playing devil's advocate because
good games or we you they never got a
chance to come over the game is
fantastic
there's a lot of other games there
that's fantastic
price point really doesn't matter
because once you add in the portability
of the game the game actually lends
itself to giving you equal value or
extra value
I'm glad you say that because I know
that's another point of contention a lot
of people like you know that the quote
unquote Nintendo tax when the car see
for me to wear look is the same I'm
looking at the portability factor
can I take I would love to take ex-con
to right now my xbox one on the goal I
can't do it you saying but I got a title
you know mean for switch and if it like
I said I wanted to do and being
playgrounds and stuff like that don't
think it's funny how the ExCom dev said
if I knew [ __ ] like that was even even
possible for being secretive about what
this witch can do for so long because if
you look at the power of the switches
which is nearly three times as powerful
as the Wii U if you look at you the Wii
U is about it is as powerful as 360 ps3
if not a little more powerful so I mean
it's a capable machine so and
they just didn't get out there and
really and let these people know like an
illicit man like this is something you
can really work with now so now people
are late to the game you know hopefully
you will see the third-party support
that we've always wanted at least more
of it ah you know what you know but
Nintendo likes to do is it like the
control the narrative of and everything
on Xbox we could play right dead
redemption those are games somebody was
in my Twitter line this really weird
dude strange guy hey strange guy
he was on my Twitter line you were sure
you were in there talking about our
PlayStation that's 500 more games than
Xbox and my question to you was what are
you counting you know he was just
throwing out numbers there listen if
we're counting everything from the Xbox
and the Xbox is a family brand big
number like that clearly you know them
all want you to name on 500 - the guy in
my timeline which was crazy but I'm just
saying Xbox is a brand in his family and
it stretches and they added the LG Xbox
to it and it's know that those games
will be available later on so you're
talking about games that span
generations and you you can't equate
that to a 500 number because PlayStation
if you're saying PlayStation now and
you're adding those games in there so
you might as well add our games in as
well I don't think it comes close yeah I
mean listen the fact of the matter is
this as much as people who also say you
know this no one wants to play all games
and all some stuff we have approves and
put and look at what crash right now is
doing right yeah look what crash is
doing right look at what on black ops 2
did a month as soon as it got announced
so again people want to play these old
games that people are complaining you
know so again I think a lot of time is
that disconnect and all sovereign's
talked about it is between the hardcore
gaming which is us thinking that they
represented
majority and the majority says look we
want to play those only we want to go
back to that and the same thing
happening with Nintendo back to the set
you know these these games that people
didn't play and now they get the chance
let me jump in on this topic or quit all
right you know for the most part it's
just like you it's just like I saw
someone in the chat say a lot of people
in you know Lord sovereign said a lot of
people did not get away you for it for
the most part they made solid games on
the Wii U now do I think they need to
know overboard and start pouring
everything for the will you
halo no but stuff like Bayonetta - stuff
like Super Smash Brothers I wouldn't
mind that okay - Bayonetta yep I never
played that I would I would I would be
happy if I saw these games ported you
know 60 is absurd if they if they
watched you know a lot of these HD
roommates like $29.99 39 obviously it's
not happening because it's Newton I'd be
okay but you know I have to admit man I
can't I hate that I'm about to say this
I paid $60 for Super Smash Brothers I do
remember when we did the the Wii U
prediction nothing weed then it's in a
prediction thing I was right they didn't
announce Super Smash Brothers I said it
would conflict with orbs everyone said
Oh stupid you did you just say that you
know they dropped the mic moment would
be Metroid and they'd drop the mic they
did they contender's not in the wave
right man like it I can't even get mad
at grandpa doing what he do
[Music]
[Applause]
for putting that lookie-lookie app out
of this
[Applause]
acquisitions going on right now leave
Logitech's in the news what's going on
Lord sovereign what life's tech there's
a lot detect this past week purchased
Astro gaming for the humble amount of 85
million dollars not money so actually a
lot detect the past couple years would
make it to move we have this acquisition
now with Astro
they bought SciTech a couple years ago
so Logitech is really kind of cementing
the this you know they kind of stand in
the PC gaming space definitely everybody
knows them for their um for the for the
gaming mice their gaming keyboards um
and their headsets but the headsets have
always been more kind of their budget
like had not you know the highest maybe
you pay for a lot of stick headset and
maybe 150 dollars so the fact that they
purchase Astro is interesting um
interesting because it shows that they
want to make headway in the console
space which is for them to do that you
know you have to now start attacking the
turtle beach's you have to start
attacking um what is this uh the plain
tronics the Lucid sound now exactly
sounds coming here with the Scorpio
right that's another thing with Dolby
Atmos becoming more prevalent now in
this next coming generation we talked
about the X and the ps4 Pro they want to
throw their hat in that arena um and I
think by acquiring Astro that allows
them to eight take the Astro name um
more global but I mean you talk about
when you talk about loud to save their
company with a lot of capital and huge
global reach if it's if there's a reason
why they were able to purchase Astro for
85 million dollars only as that Astro
doesn't have
they don't have the reach that a la
bridge has it is sort of it's kind of
it's a boutique type of of headset where
it's not for everybody it's an expensive
headset there's a lot of tech in it and
I think that's the reason why you don't
see it selling for more than 85 million
dollars because it's something that the
enthusiasts purchase so not by adding
them to the logitech family now the
thinking is that they're gonna bring
down the prices of these headsets or
they ain't gonna incorporate the
Astrotech into logitech sets and make
sort of middle-of-the-road headsets that
are not you know $300 so I think it's a
win-win for everybody across the board I
think it's a Power Move for Logitech
moving into like expanding more into the
PC space and now expanding into the
console space turtlebeach has to look
out loose it has to look out Natron
exactly yeah yeah I definitely jump on
this on this because um I'm a huge Astro
has that guy you know um I just recently
picked up their the third generation
after 8:15 I'm a sucker for a fifties I
think they're just they're like oh this
is the best game has said a lot of shout
out to the Destiny community you know
shout out to dad Oh a lot of these guys
are using Nashville as well and it's
like you said kind of like a boutique on
thing where it's a very expensive
headset it's not cheap you know they
were one of the earlier ones do one
believe one true 7.1 and I just love I
think to me that when they I fell in
love with them as the fact you can just
flip the mic boom up and that
automatically mutes your chat I'm going
to you so I I love them personally so
when I heard this really trying to get
in the game you know kind of thing so
yeah it would be interesting to see
because I think they could start to
expand their reach yeah there's a lot of
like put it like put it this way looking
like not I got to generation threes I
gave my generation twos to uh Lord mark
smooth God he's like yo heads off and
I'm like this is what I've been playing
with you can see he had a footsteps of
someone in Call of Duty or battlefield
you know I mean that kind of stuff so um
yeah I think
a cool move I think Logitech is
expanding in reach I think they're
trying to get the game obviously like
lost I'm saying we got on I'm so sounds
combat motion is coming you know I'll be
interested to see a point of I think
they've already started versions because
astral has a right now
right and I thought they were gonna be
newer than the a 50s but they're
actually like a kind of like a less
version but like real flexible they
still do for our virtual 7.1 but they
like inexpensive so it's like the
bargain-basement 850 that almost give
you everything 50 I've never seen astral
priced that low because I think you can
get him cheetah now for like maybe 60 70
whatever like that yeah they're not that
expensive they after they called the
a-10s the astral eight sends a shout out
to astral gaming if you're Astor headset
on the round table
middle of the ground type of guy I don't
really go over $200 on my headsets and
and I'm I'm sorry I'm not doing them a
good service right now I actually have
some really good headsets the headsets
that I do have with what is the gears of
wars a limited edition headsets I forgot
who made them sorry
also I have these um what is these these
HyperX headsets this is really good too
but shout out to Microsoft for I don't
know the developers name and our own
company's name they gave us these Dolby
Atmos headsets they are fantastic so um
listen if they can get it in the price
range and I know I'm the XS gamer but in
certain things I don't see the viability
and certain things but I do
that at a certain level I'm getting that
premium experience without paying the
premium dollar for it and I I really
don't play too much with my headsets on
most the time it's really for chat so I
understand you guys are ecstatic with
this
I'm excited from the standpoint that if
what Louis Aafrin says that they're
gonna make a middle-of-the-road headset
where I can go in I can drop down 100
$150 on a head one right now yeah the
astral iTunes right now see that's what
I'm talking about that's definitely
that's a clear yeah that's where I'm at
with it that's my like like that's the
system and I'm not doing it you can
literally Bend these things like in a
360 degree angle I don't break and to
Lord Kings point like he said they
doesn't use the headset as much I'm
assuming he's using the surround sound
but uh surround sound honestly a lot of
people using it less and less especially
now the moment surround sound really
jumped from 5.1 to 7.1 and it became a
little more difficult to get you know
space wise to get seven surround
speakers now what Apple's you look about
speakers on the ceiling sound above you
so in the viability of that in an
apartment and stuff it's getting smaller
and smaller so the headset market to me
is expanding even more because of that
because you're gonna have more people
wanting to get the simulated surround
sound because my bows the matter is
looking is what you're doing is two
traditional spirits cuz I'm glad you
brought this or something because I had
a dilemma before I bought the da 50s a
new one and I was like you know Dolby
Atmos is coming should I wait should I
not that about and for what I was
hearing its shout out to the Xbox one
ready line cuz these guys help me out I
got a lot of audio files that really
helped me out with my question and for
what I heard unless you have what Lord
King has which is the traditional set up
from a surround sound standpoint
basically what they're trying to say to
us all is that
this is all software based inside a hex
yeah it's not it's not that it's a
hustle but it's simulated it's not going
to be the exact sound which stuff is
coming from the ceiling with a Dolby
Atmos setup traditional in your house
right so what they see a lot of this is
kind of stereo still I mean you got to
think about it when we're looking at
these head says that are touting like
the date you know onboard Dolby Atmos
processing it's kind of it is it is all
it is all just kind of software yes but
isn't it true just it's the gamer is the
games at the gamer place
so these Call of Duty guys these Halo
war guys these guys that are actually
playing tactical games that need to be
in contact with their teammates and so
they can hear that the you know the
gunshots and they can hear the footsteps
and they can actually are positioning
and stuff like that that lends more to
the headset guide me traditionally I'm
like Lord sovereign to be honest with
you I'm playing by myself in my living
room with my surround sound cranked as
high as it could possibly go
TV shining in my face and I'm playing
like you know a single-player experience
type of thing that I don't really need
to be in a chat or have a headset on and
that's the only time I put my headset on
is when I get a party invite or you know
I want to you know talk to somebody
about something and I'm not hearing
music I'm not hearing gunshots I'm not
hearing anything I'm just talking to
somebody so for me personally the
viability in purchasing a $350 headset
it misses me terribly oh yeah nothing
that you inquired on this this whole
headset situation where you at with all
this way yet with Logitech
so easy
my question is now you are you've got
those Plantronics those dolby atmos have
those been treating you sir they've been
good you still like so you doing okay
you're doing them with the attachment
straight through with the UM right now I
know that you did a blue microphone all
I got but you've never had a pair of
Astral hats that's correct yes I owe you
had so what was your three only broke
down on you one of them dead I gave one
of them away and I don't really know
what happened to the third one is the
glow no afterglow say something about
half the glow and you know some of that
nature
yeah I was liking after going to the
honeymoon phase ended logitech position
close this thing out any loads got
anything else we're going to bring to
the table for we finish this thing cool
so you do our outros here's another one
in the books
Lord sovereign where can the final
people find you on twitter at Lord Saab
ILP Lord Akram then you got a lot of
things going on in these streets
another addicts show what's going on
with you yeah nothing to really talk
about at the moment I'm still getting
stuff together I do have one of my first
addict debates it's probably gonna come
out in August it's I'm going to have it
it's going to be three people debating
three people judging obviously maybe in
the hold and it's going to be what
platforms going to when south wise this
holiday so uh
that together I'll probably try to get
you know someone on this panel to be one
of the judges I'm trying to get like you
know people as close as biased as I can
true bias as I can get like unbiased
bodies no trees people I can get
unbiased as possible by yeah people I
can get unbiased as possible so I'm
looking at people like you know Carol
from tick I'm looking at like dizzy from
playback gaming make sure no it's not
art question the topic will be on this
guy got a preview program patch on his
chest you know definitely getting that
in I do I do want to have an addict show
about why the Xbox one is losing in
selves because hit me and kid argue
about that all the time so I actually
want to do it had a show on it so we'll
get we'll get to that later
definitely follow me on Twitter I uh you
know Lord addict I ope
I definitely be announcing more stuff as
I get closer into these release titles I
appreciate you guys coming into the
podcast I saw a couple people that's new
to my sets new sub sub to me in the chat
appreciate you coming over here to the
podcast so definitely definitely sub to
the because we do this every Sunday at
1:00 we we're always happy to see new
people in there you know comment well we
definitely interact with the comment
section so that's and you know I'm gonna
talk to the panel after the podcast
about doing something new next week so
stay tuned for that
follow the iron Lords chat follow all
you know all that stuff's in the
description definitely appreciate shout
out to you the plan Xbox you guys there
stuff cooking over there too nice moving
those guys so that's cool and of course
Lord King XS game Instagram Twitter
Facebook and all that other stuff but
check this out right now the bit of
brother podcast is about to be starting
folks my cartoon is the engineer we
already got the sound for the intro and
outro that's already you know cemented
what we working on as the the intro for
the cartoon logo stuff like that so I
have lured SWAT on my my logos so you
know here being the credits and stuff
like that but that podcast is going to
be a little bit different from what you
guys get in here that podcast is going
to be on a bunch of things so we're
gonna be talking entertainment boxing
status hobbies comic books and it's also
going to be video so you guys actually
gonna get a chance to interact with me
merch all that stuff will be there so
you can get a little bit of King in your
life a little bit so his question
looking can a not be the brother I said
the bearded brother brother
holy dude you guys check that a little
king is a character and definitely worth
watching we can have people on that
podcast so you can have people on that
podcast we wouldn't let on this brought
to the gaming realist
always telling you what you not
necessarily don't like to hear which is
what you need to hear but on you shouts
everybody to chat today on deftly heavy
metals layer fastback all all of the
usual faces that we see definitely click
that like and subscribe it really does
especially subscribe why we trying to do
big things and I'm like what attic said
we got some more stuff cooking up it's
gonna be great you can farm again
all in YouTube social medias on
Twitter's Lord Cognito follow me there
and then obviously when I love podcast
please subscribe
SoundCloud iTunes U and on that note we
are out o Lord sovereign